so now I'm going to present you using
wall that is making a adult called
constant flow white and deep about say
classifications via Z Y please give a
warm applause thank you very much and my
name is Yu Feng and I am a developer
advocate at Google working on machine
learning tensorflow
that sort of thing and so I want to
start off with just a general I want to
take a poll of the audience can you
raise your hand if you use machine
learning in some way in your work or in
your personal time in the evenings for
your personal projects things like that
so lots of people not everyone but I'd
say that was probably 2/3 maybe 3/4 of
people so that's that's really great to
see and as many of you know of course
machine learning seems to be eating
software which is eating the world so
taking over know machine learning is
it's really cool and there's lots of
ways to utilize it of course so today
I'm just going to focus on one specific
piece and that's classification so
supervised learning and classifying
generally speaking here we're going to
be targeting structured data so not
audio files or pictures or videos or
people running around it's CSV files
basically or database tables so I
figured that would be kind of
appropriate for this audience we had a
number of present workshops yesterday
kind of talking about working with
tables compression format all that stuff
so once you finish organizing your data
and you're ready to do stuff with it
this is where we kind of pick up so for
the portion of the audience who did not
raise their hands earlier this is my one
slide overview of all love machine
learning okay maybe just a little bit of
machine learning so my definition of
machine learning in the fewest number of
words possible is using many examples
to answer questions six words took a
while but I eventually got it down to
just six words and if we take these six
words and we now split them into two
halves two sides we arrive at the
primary two components of machine
learning the training and the prediction
and both sides are equally important
because we want to be able to answer
questions and a lot of times we are lost
in the training side and forget that the
real purpose of building these models of
tuning them gathering the data cleaning
the data maybe even compressing the data
is to actually use it for something to
answer these questions and of course we
can do this both locally and if we have
a lot of data in the cloud or maybe on
many many machines sometimes someone
else's machines and so today we're going
to be using tensorflow
this is Google's open source machine
learning library I think a few of you
may have heard of it and it was open
sourced in November of 2015
so now it's been what is it almost a
year and a half now and tensorflow is
now at 1.1 actually today the 1.2
released candidate 0 just came out it's
folks want to play with that that just
got dropped on github today and it's
built to be not just fast and easy to
use and all that but is also at its core
built to be scalable it's built on a
distributed runtime so tensorflow the
name comes from the word sensor which is
I think why her detectable I'd never
heard the word tensor in my life and so
I was like tensorflow of that it sounds
cool I wonder what it means it probably
stands for something so tensor is wrist
another fancy word for matrix which is
really just a fancy word for array right
if we twist the definitions a little and
then Flo is referring to the tensors
these matrices flowing on a graph
something like this not nothing fancy
right it's just some numbers going into
an add operation
and the result coming out the other side
now the important byproduct of this
structuring is that you have to execute
it with what's called deferred execution
and that means you construct the graph
first and then push numbers through it
so we'll see when we play with the code
that there will be kind of two distinct
phases where we do the construction and
then we push numbers through it and of
course tensorflow supports many
platforms beyond just the typical CPU
and GPU it also runs natively on Android
iOS raspberry pi and there's a special
compiler called Excel a linear
accelerated accelerated linear algebra
which allows you to actually write
compilers for custom hardware custom
architectures so you can put it into
other embedded devices as well
and so as I was mentioning earlier
tensorflow runs on a distributed
execution engine at its core luckily we
don't have to work with it at its core
because it's a lot of C++ code and I
know some of you probably really enjoyed
C++ code but since its high data we're
going to be working with Python so on
top of C++ we have a Python front-end
but even that is relatively low level
you are manipulating the graph manually
by hand and while you know based on that
in the picture I showed manipulating the
graph by hand seems like the natural
approach we can actually abstract to a
higher level and in fact several higher
levels and first is layers layers runs
on top of the built-in front-end and
that helps you build basically layers of
your network but if you want to abstract
even further you can use what we call
the estimator class or use carrots and
you can use that basically those
libraries help wrap the operation with
even building the network by hand and
take care of the entire training and
evaluation work flow and you can
abstract it even further and we have
canned estimators which basically takes
care of the entire loop and supplies a
number of built-in defaults that you can
change but a lot of reasonable defaults
best practice
are built into that and so we're going
to play with that today because it's a
demo and the demo gods don't like
complicated things so this is this easy
kind of straightforward getting started
I call it kind of your first pass you
know instead of putting your data into
Excel and plotting a linear regression
on your data consider doing something
like this because it's we're getting to
a point where running so tomorrow is so
straightforward that you can basically
just do that as a first pass and see how
it turns out and then fine tune it from
there
so this is a simple example of using a
canned estimator and well we'll get into
the code but the part I want you to pay
attention to is that middle portion
where it says DNN deep neural networks
classifier and so right here in the
middle the parameters are just passing
what we need to and you might say well
what if I want to customize it more or
you can you can customize it a ton and
there's lots of arguments we won't get
into all the details with these
arguments but this is just the show that
you can do a lot before you're forced to
building by hand so at this why I wanted
to step X in the code real quick and
give you a little context for the model
that we're going to be actually working
with the deep and wide model so this is
a little short story so let's say you
have a great new idea you're going to
build the next hot app it's going to be
great and it's a magical food app it's
going to predict what your users want to
eat based on what they say to the app
and deliver it to them it's a totally
original right so naturally you launch
and iterate you say ok you know people
say what they want we're just going to
match what they say by text it's going
to be text matching string matching and
so they say Fried Chicken you give them
chicken fried rice not really the same
thing
people wanted Fried Chicken you know
they want something like chicken and
waffles or chicken with like french
fries something like that right so
that's okay I got a v2 v2 is going to
use much
learning you know machine learning so
you use machine learning you train a
linear model and with the linear model
you can basically memorize what people's
preferences are and so now you know
you're doing pretty well you're you're
mapping you know fried chicken - chicken
and waffles and you're saying don't give
them chicken fried rice if they say -
fried chicken but if maybe if they say
fried rice you give them chicken fried
rice there's a problem though users get
bored because you've memorized what they
want so every time they say fried
chicken you give them chicken and
waffles every single time right so after
the fourth or the 14th or the 40th time
people get a little bored and so they
want to see similar but different foods
and so you say that's ok I know we use
deep learning yes and so with deep
learning you can give generalized
recommendations and now your app is once
again on the up and to the right growth
curve and you can give these generalized
recommendations and here I want to step
back and talk about this concept of
indebtedness it was a deep network what
you get why is it useful is because you
can embed your concepts your food items
into a basically what actually turns out
to be a lower dimensional space then it
would otherwise so in the linear
representation we basically have one
giant array one element per food ok and
so maybe you have a thousand food maybe
you have ten thousand different foods
and so you were raised that long and
essentially that's how many dimensions
are a thousand dimensions 10,000
dimensions but with an embedding space
what you end up doing is you get to
arrange all of those food items into
let's say just the 8 dimensional space
ok and that allows you to cluster things
that are close together literally near
each other the example I use to describe
how kind of picture that's with it's
hard to picture an 8 dimensional space
right so what you do is you take a piece
of paper two dimensions and I say okay
here is a blank piece of paper I want
you to draw a circle for every food I
give you and I want you to draw these
circles near each other and so you start
I start saying
you know watermelon pineapple
strawberries dude put all the fruits
together and then I start saying you
know chickens show these things you put
the meat together and then I said you
know rice pasta noodles and bread and
you put those together and as I need
more and more and more things there are
certain things that get a little tricky
where do you put fruit pie well need to
be near the fruit and it needs to be
near the desserts but I accidentally put
the desserts here and the fruit here and
there's meat in the middle and that
doesn't really work so you need a higher
dimensional space so I say great I give
you a third dimension here's a box now
you can put things up and you can
arrange them so that they can be things
can be closer together where they need
to be closed and things can be further
apart where they need to be farther
apart and so you can generalize this to
more and more dimensions allowing you to
push and pull things where they need to
be so that's what an embedding space is
representing and by doing that you can
see what's close to any given location
in that space great so you've built a
deep neural networks your users are
enjoying it but there's still a problem
they are still picky why because when
they ask for something specific you are
still giving them something similar so
when they say I want a decaf
iced latte with nonfat milk and you give
them a hot latte with whole milk they
don't like that so you you need to be
able to understand when someone wants a
specific request and what's the one want
they just give the general request for
some food so you have to balance eat -
right and so basically the solution here
is this is paper that came out on not
too many years ago like a recent dish
called wide and deep and you combine
these two you say - I'm going to take
the wide or the linear regression and
the deep network and put them into one
big network and this allows you to
basically generalize most things and
then the wide side it memorizes the
exceptions so why didn't deep allows you
to get memorization
and generalization and with these I
meant having that in this structure you
train it all together some things go one
side some things go the other and it's
all one big network now you might say
well this looks like it could be
complicated if this drawing which is
just the cartoon version of the real
thing looks like this and the real thing
must be crazy right so that's why we
don't want to manipulate the graph
manually because building this by hand
well someone did that already
right is this great research and so we
we should just be able to use this
research take advantage of this research
and work on top of it just just leverage
it use it and so that's the end of my
story time and we're going to now
actually use it so our data set is just
as exciting as good it's census data yes
and the task is to predict whether or
not a given household has over 50,000 in
annual income and so this was from the
1994 census so adjust your expectations
accordingly and there's about 32,000
training examples in here and about
16,000 dot for evaluation and so let's
let's take a look at the columns so
first we have things you did basically
things you'd expect age education where
there were how much I've occasionally
said education but um
marital status things like their
relationship their gender raise capital
gains how many hours they work per week
those sorts of things nothing crazy here
and of course last but not least we have
the income bracket which is just
categorical either you're above or below
50k now the point I want to draw your
attention to is that there are two kinds
of columns here primarily categorical
and continuous some columns are
categorical in that they might just be
two different values all the values are
just selected from two or five different
values and certain values are continuous
they span a whole range right like
things like age or capital gains and so
these two divisions categorical and
continuous
map to our wide and deep on the wide
side you have basically categorical
things you want to be able you can
basically sort of memorize those because
they're just discrete values whereas on
a deep side it's continuous so it's a
continuous space and so you want to be
able to generalize among them and
another set of words that I'll use to
describe this is sparse index so sparse
maps to wide and dense maps to
continuous and so we'll so we'll see
some of those terms pop up and I'll try
to mention all the different versions of
the same word but they could keep this
in mind in terms of what's what really
means the same thing so let's go to the
code if you want you can follow along
your laptop's this is the repo I'll show
it again at the end but you certainly do
not have to you know follow along to you
all show you everything on screen as
well
so here we're going to be running in
Jupiter notebook and let's see the first
question as usual is to ask can you guys
see this or shred make it bigger any
votes for bigger bigger any more votes
for bigger and he votes for smaller okay
nobody ever wants it smaller so the
first thing we're going to do is just
import some stuff
nothing crazy here tensorflow gets
imported as usually as TF so later we'll
see TF in the code it's mostly just so
you don't have to type out the word
tensorflow every time in case you spell
it wrong and there's a verbosity setting
here typically you don't need to do this
if the default will be Warren I'm going
to change this to info and this will
give us more info but it'll also give us
a bunch of internal warnings and
deprecation signals and things like that
so we will scroll past those to the
useful stuff when we get to it and
another useful thing I sometimes do I
like to do is print the version of
tensorflow like I said right now
tensorflow is 1.1 until maybe two weeks
ago I had 1.0 installed so whenever I
run it I'd like to see what version am i
running on and I in the right virtual
environment things like that and so we
talked about there being category
columns so here I'm just storing some of
the column names in different arrays
we'll take advantage of that shortly so
when we run this cell and let's move on
so the data is in a CSV this part is of
course optional in terms of tensor file
but it's kind of nice to play with your
data a little bit get a sense of what
it's doing and so here I just loaded
into pandas and passed in the column
names and you can see here our data is
pretty much what you'd expect we have
these our course to describe only shows
you the numerical columns the data is
distributed in some odd ways in some
cases you look at education number right
it's a number it's not a education
category so that's a number that goes it
looks like from one to sixteen and each
one of those values maps to a different
level of Education
and you see here we have aged we are
seeing ages ranging from as low as 17
years almost up to 90 years old and so
with average and you know median of 38
mean of 37 mean of 38 so it seems to be
reasonably representative most people
are working about 40 hours a week are 25
and 50 and even at 75 only 45 hours a
week so tight distribution there and so
another thing that and then here is an
example of the actual data itself so
some some of the columns are our words
and some of the columns are numbers so
the other piece of pandas that when I
found about out about I thought pretty
magical is the computing the cross
correlation between columns it's kind of
a this probably if we're doing today is
called the first pass this is probably
the bureau it's passed right to the
cross-correlation see if there's
anything that directly maps to your
answer in the first place and you can
see here there's there's not too much
going on most of the values are on the
small side of things and so this is kind
of a kind of problem that you want to
throw at machine learning is something
with a little signal from every single
column but no one column that is
dominating even with that you can use
the little ones to improve your
prediction but here we almost don't have
enough information to do a first
prediction just using classical
techniques so with that out of the way
let's move on to you know more more
tensorflow so the first thing we want to
do is I have a function here that
returns a function and basically this
function is just playing getting the
data into the graph plain and simple
reads in the CSV this is the boring part
so I'm not going to go into it too much
basically all you need to know is it's a
function where provided the filename it
will read that CSV and return a
dictionary like this of the data and
tensorflow and we'll see how sensible
handles that oh I should run these cells
because that would be helpful
okay so now we get to the interesting
part we got to consider some columns and
this this step is I'd say like a decent
chunk of the meat of this approach and
what we have are called feature columns
right so by we have a library inside
layers which allows you to consider
these columns based on whether they are
categorical or continuous sparse or
dense and the first thing we'll do is
we'll do deal with the sparse columns
the categorical columns and we have two
tools at our disposal one is called
sparse column width keys and the other
one is called sparse column with hash
market the keys with keys means that you
are providing the values directly you
are stating these are the possible
values for this column so for example in
that particular census the values for
gender and race were just these few and
you can provide them rather than having
tensorflow detect them automatically
basically and then here we have sparse
column with hash bucket and for this
it's in situations where you don't know
the explicit full range of possible
unique values so maybe you're collecting
data from a form and you just decided to
leave one of the questions free text
entry so people can type whatever they
want all sorts of garbage into there and
so after you clean it up you're like I
still don't really know what with all
the possible things people put in so you
put a hash bucket size based on what you
set the maximum number of unique values
could be and so that's I just gone ahead
and did that for these other columns um
for situations where maybe you have like
a hundred columns that you want to type
this out using sparse column with hash
buckets it's a decent approach you can
just loop the whole thing and generate
names for each column c1 c2 c3 and so I
keep forgetting to run the cells this
has happened before and then I get to
the bottom and I say okay now we're
going to run it in and nothing works so
here we have continuous columns right so
after we do feel the sparse console have
a couple of the continuous ones they're
much easier
you basically just map them to a
real-valued column that's it
and what you'll notice here with both of
these when we did these we've never
actually hooked it up to the data right
all we did was we said you know here's a
real-valued column it's called H that's
always said we said here's a string and
so we're going to need to take care of
that later right but for now this is
fine and I need to run this cell to okay
so now that we have these kind of base
columns we can do a few transformations
this is kind of the interesting part
we've set up our base layer we've mapped
all the columns to two names okay that
of course we need to do that but now
what we can do is we can do some
transformations we can take the age and
Buckett eyes them we can say well what
if we wanted age to be categorical this
continuous before but what if we want to
make a categorical version because we
care about age ranges so we say okay
here are the boundaries and we can
basically have a bucket our column and
then we can also cross columns so we can
take two categorical columns and say
when we want when we have education and
occupation in specific caring's to have
tentacle find those rather than just
having them in the jumble in the
haystack we point out here the needle
associate these two needles together
basically and we can in fact even cross
some of the things we transform through
here we have three columns crossed
together one of those columns is age
buckets which was itself right a bucket
eyes continuous column so you can begin
to see there's a lot of options here you
can cross as many columns as you feel
like having your computer work through
but and then you do pass in a bucket
size which should be the same order of
magnitude as the sum of the orders of
magnitude of the base categories on the
cell okay and so now that we've created
our future columns sparse and dense and
then we have transformed them together
we're just going to group them we're
going to make two arrays for all these
columns that we created so if you see
here we have our sprout columns we have
our transformed cross columns below them
and then we have another variable for
deep columns and inside deep deep
columns we can do one further
transformation and here we take all of
our previously categorical columns
gender raised native country occupation
and what we have is we have this
embedding column right hopefully
everyone remembers what an embedding is
and we remember that that was in the
deep side of things right so we take
these categorical values and we embed
them into this 8 dimensional in this
case space so that they can be used by
the deep neural network we let the deep
neural network eat up all the possible
values so that it gets all information
so that's it right we we create these
two arrays and we still haven't hooked
up the data yet of course and so now
let's create that and it's going to give
us some warnings about dividing by
square roots and so now we get to create
our model and what I have here is
basically a simple helper function that
generates a unique string to create a
direct a model directory to store all
the values and you have 3 3 different
models here we have both are all the
versions of our app that both linear
regression will have be deep network and
we have the wide and deep network and so
for the linear case we simply pass in
the wide columns right and then for the
deep case we pass in the deep columns
and then for the other one we pass in
both and we there's one more argument
here model directory model directory
represents just the folder it's
literally a strength so we just pass in
the folder that we want tensorflow to
use to store it's kind of the artifacts
of this training and we'll see why
that's useful in a moment and so we have
our model directory our columns and then
for the deeps case we pass in hidden
units that's just a fancy word for the
number of neurons we want per layer so
this is kind of part of this
configuration we can basically say if I
want a two layer network with a hundred
nodes in the first layer and 50 nodes in
the second layer we can just pass an
array of 150 and if then we say you know
let's see what happens if we have three
layers you just say comma space 25 and
now we have a third layer
and I can say well here's a fourth layer
and so on and so with widen peep we
combine all these arguments together we
have our wide and deep columns and then
again we have our let me scroll down for
you and then we have our hidden units as
well and so this is just kind of a
helper function for me right to easily
select which model to build if you were
just playing experimenting with this you
might you know maybe you start with this
and then when you want to go to a
different one you could just literally
just change the method call from D and M
classifier to DN and linear combined
classifier and so that that makes it
easy kind of to play around so let's go
ahead and build this and remember we're
doing this for execution so when I run
this cell it's going to return right
away after putting some stuff about the
configuration but basically it just
builds the graph but nothing is running
through it because we haven't hooked up
the data so now we get to hook up the
data finally the steps that you've all
been waiting for
maybe and so what we have here is
literally oh yes I should point this out
when we created our model I might get
model function we returned M and model
direct for M of course it was our model
itself okay and so and externally I'm
also calling at M and so we're going to
pay attention to em every time I see em
something we know we're working with our
model and we're going to there's a
number of method calls built into this
class instance and so we have m dot
zipped so this is the training this will
do all of your training looping it will
manage you know saving off checkpoints
and running and it also supplies all the
learning rates and things like that so
we do end up it and we pass in two
things one is the input function that
was the function from earlier that takes
our data given the file name
pushes it into tensorflow so this
function returns one training batch per
call so it returns well it returns the
graph that returns one training batch
and then the steps would say how many
steps we want if we don't provide this
argument it will run forever and you
will be sad so provide this value so if
we run this again something I probably
should have run earlier it will boot up
tensorflow show me a number of warnings
because we said info and what's
interesting about using info once you
get past the random warnings which will
go away is that you get to you get to
watch the training happen in real time
now remember in our code we didn't
configure anything about learning rate
we didn't configure our choice of
optimizer we didn't configure what
metrics were to display but it will
basically supply some reasonable
defaults to already and then let's see
here so here we go we have our initial
set of kind of training laws and so once
it's set up it runs pretty quick because
you know this is not a huge model and we
have our training all of our losses are
printed by default of course it doesn't
have any notion of accuracy yet and so
we have so that that's it right we did
it in 45 seconds and our training loss
which is relatively meaningless to you
is just point two seven but let's take a
look at how it did in terms of accuracy
right because that's the piece we
actually care about and so 4x4
evaluation it's just m dot evaluate so
our operational models we create our
model m and we do induct it and we do m
evaluate and with the evaluation it's
almost exactly the same argument the
time moment passed in the evaluation
file which I'm calling the test file
here the values which was up here see
here we had the test file and we could
see yeah and then it returns a result
object which contains a number of useful
metrics one of which happens to the
accuracy so I'm going to pull that out
display it so we see here it does our
200 evaluation steps and once I scroll
past them all which it shows as you can
see here we have this dictionary of
values inside of which we pull out just
this accuracy at the bottom so we did
83% sometimes this shows up as 82
sometimes 84 there's always a little
natural variability and one of the
things that's fun to do we don't have
time today onstage to do this but if you
get this notebook you can play around
with it you can change it up the feature
columns which ones you use you can
change the transformations you can
change of course the model how many
layers how big those layers are how big
the patches are there's many many many
different transformations that you can
do and what's neat about this kind of
setup is that it allows you to easily
iterate across different trials you can
play with different numbers and not have
to muck up everything else it's just
like I want to change this thing I'll
get change it rerun change it rerun and
so you get a nice tight development loop
which is which is really nice and so the
final thing that useful kind of that
we'll talk about today with this m dot
something is m dot export saved model
because when you're done training when
you finish optimizing all your things
you want to export a nice result and so
C or the prediction side of things right
and when we are doing prediction we're
going to want to have not the same
training graphs that we used for
training and this is because when you're
training we have lots of things built in
for this back propagation and feedback
loops and things like that and all the
different metrics that you're measuring
but when we're running prediction we're
done with training right we don't want
to change the values anymore we don't
really care how things you know what
gradients are coming out and things like
that we just want a blazing fast
prediction book that is nice and tight
and so we need to change the variables
into constants we want to strip out any
nodes that are unnecessary
just make it blazing fast and so
tensorflow has a built-in function to do
that for you so you can basically call
export state model this is another
basically input function that helps map
inputs to the graph that you basically
don't have to touch even if you supply
new datasets that's another cool thing
about we have structured this for you
and then you basically just supply that
function and a string pack is the folder
to save it to and it just exports that
model for you so that runs pretty
seamlessly so it just loads up the graph
and then export it out for you keep in
mind that this graph once is exported is
not something that you can use for more
training right because it's just the
prediction graph it's been stripped down
it no longer works for training and so
when you do want to train again let's
say you you train for 10000 steps and
now you have some new data and you don't
want to start over you want to start on
step 10001 what do you do you can pass
in the same model directory and it will
use the checkpoint files that are
already stayed there that it saves there
for you without you having to do
anything it will just pick up where it
left off load up the existing variables
and it will continue training at step
10,001 and so that's that's a really
nice kind of built-in feature of working
that's kind of this level of abstraction
so now you have a prediction graph you
need to be able to do something useful
with it right we want to answer those
questions and tensorflow also has this
thing called tensorflow serving another
open source package inside sensor flow
that takes care of running your
blazing-fast model and at you know
basically in production on your data
centers and so it's a c++ binary that
just works out of the box you just need
to load it up configure it into whatever
environment you may be running in
whatever maybe you have containerized
environment maybe you have it running on
some kind of host service and it will
just take care of that for you and right
now google has a
it's called Google cloud and our engine
machine learning engine which it does
training but it also has a prediction
service which lets you load in those
exported prediction graphs and basically
spins up a scalable web server for you
and we hope since we already released
the potential of serving as an
open-source thing we want to see other
you know options out there right so
that's why the last bullet here hosted
across I want to be able to add more
bullets here so that you can have you
know options just like you have options
to deploy your web servers to different
places as well and so you know the the
mo engine just as a brief kind of intro
demo to that you can basically you
create a model there's this notion of
models and versions the model is just a
shell for containing all the versions of
your model so you create a model maybe
you just you give it some name and
that's all you get so again you see that
theme where we just provide a string and
nothing else and users to go to know
what to do with it and so you give a
string and so we create a model and
that's kind of useless because you have
no versions so you create a version and
maybe you call it v1 and you pass in you
need a pass in a folder a pass to in
this case to cloud storage so you know I
the export saves out and family sure to
show you briefly here I know we're kind
of 10 on time so we saw here export it
exported to this nice cool down for you
it exported to this folder right so we
just did this and so I'm going to go to
that directory here and make this bigger
first and we're going to CD into this
directory and you see here we have two
two listings here one is a dot PB file
and then one is a variable folder and so
inside of that variables folder are just
two small files that hold the saved
variables so the dot PB is the structure
of the graph and then the variables are
for the actual safe weights so similarly
I have here two basically if you just
upload these two files into the cloud
and then you pass in that path and then
you can click create and then you you
basically have a
scale to zero also auto scaling up web
server that runs the predation graph for
you so if you guys have you ever used
like App Engine like a similar kind of
experience there and you can of course
do all of this from the command line you
can create model and create versions
directly from there same arguments so
you can script that out as you please
and then with prediction you pass in the
JSON so basically then you've created a
REST API and you can use it you can hit
it from anywhere mobile embedded
whatever you want it's just the REST API
so you pass in some rest call and you
can do this from the command line as
well and you can get that you back get
back to responses as probabilities as
well as classes on the Left 0 on 1 being
the predictions and if you cut it in
JSON it looks like this as you would
expect and so they're telling me I'm
running out of time so basically with
tensorflow you can you can basically
operate however you want you can train
locally and serve at scale you can flip
it around you can say I have a lot of
data I want to train in the cloud but
for reasons of network latency I want to
be able to predict locally right so then
you can operate this way because you
have that common interface of using of
this of these variables and save model
dot PB by having these exported files
you can play between you can put it
wherever you want and you can go back
and forth as you please and of course
you can do both in the cloud or both
locally that's the kind of the easy case
and so again my name is Yu cang you can
find me on twitter at you pengie
and here are some resources one is
machine learning engine of course tend
to flow that org if you haven't been to
it it's great site lots of good
tutorials built into that and then the
bottom there the to code the short links
one is for what we saw today census and
then the wide indeed passcode is a
different repo I have which basically is
the same setup but a different data set
rather quite different data set and this
one is anonymized click data so
you know working with anonymized data
you cost for some different approaches
the jupiter notebook in there as well so
you can kind of see what was different
and what was the same about using this
model on a different data set so then
maybe you can take an extend it to your
data set and then I'm hoping that this
will help you accomplish that and
finally I have tensor flow stickers if
you guys are interested help yourselves
as you can see I have a lot and you know
international travel is not getting any
easier any time soon so saves me some
space in my suitcase and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]